the tractor is the essential tool that
farmers use to do their job the tractor
operator must become very knowledgeable
about his or her tractor what it can and
what it cannot do he or she must
understand the function of all controls
and wood they should and when they
shouldn't be used it is easy to assume
that the tractor operator sees
everything that attitude will get you
into trouble very fast to be safe you
must assume that the tractor operator
doesn't have any idea that you are in
the area stay at a safe distance until
you have eyeball-to-eyeball contact and
the operator acknowledges your presence
the area between the tractor and a PTO
driven implement is one of the most
dangerous areas on the farm some call it
the no zone when in operation don't
enter it unless the tractor is stopped
the power to the PTO has been shut off
all moving parts have come to a complete
stop and the driver knows what you're
going to do and has acknowledged it if
you're not familiar with a particular
field or area walk it first become aware
of any hazards if your tractor is
equipped with a front-end loader you
have another set of dangers to deal with
always carry your load as low as
possible if your back wheels are
somewhat light and bouncy as the loader
starts to lift the load add additional
ballast to the rear of the machine be
aware that a D ballast is not always the
answer make sure you're not overloading
the equipment farm workers have been
fatally crushed because they didn't use
the proper attachment to carry the big
round bales of hay the bales roll over
on top of them one option would be to
use a spear type bale mover on the other
hand if you use grapple forks make sure
they're the correct size to handle the
bales you're moving
the master tractor driver keeps his
speed down especially when carrying a
heavy load the rig is already top-heavy
making it easier to tip over from
momentum and/or centrifugal force when
approaching a blind corner don't assume
someone coming around the other way can
hear you they might be driving a rig as
noisy as yours slow down don't drive any
faster then you can stop if suddenly
someone or something appears in your
path keep in mind your own reaction time
the same is true when driving around
curves
this is especially true at night know
the stopping distance of your tractor
and your load if you need to cross a
slope or uneven ground slow down any
irregularity in the ground might be just
enough to roll the tractor if you're
going up or down a slope don't depress
your clutch or try to change gears
always back up a slope drive down the
slope but back up it will greatly reduce
your chances of a rear rollover
sometimes you have to work in inclement
weather or after dark
often the drivers visibility is greatly
diminished cut your speed to a minimum
stay alert for holes and ditches in a
thunderstorm unless you're in a totally
enclosed cab shut the engine off set the
brakes remove the key and get off the
tractor if you're in an open field you
had a safe distance from the tractor and
lay down in the lowest ditch you can
find never stand under a tree if you're
close enough get inside a barn or
enclosed vehicle if you can hear thunder
you are within striking distance of
lightning seek safe shelter immediately
don't wait for the rain 62 people die
each year in the United States from
lightning strikes
one third of all fatal tractor accidents
happen on public roadways one third the
problem this sometimes happens when the
tractor is not the right size for towing
a certain implement but most of the time
it's the other drivers will have little
or no experience driving on country
roads that's why the tractor drivers
have to not only be concerned about
their own rate but try to anticipate
what the other drivers are going to do
don't try to keep up with road vehicles
tractors don't handle well at higher
speeds and observe the maximum highway
speed for the implement you're towing
before you set out on the highway make
sure all your hazard warning lights
headlights taillights and turn signals
are in working order be sure your smv
sign the slow moving vehicle sign is
clean and visible these will help
provide advance warning for the other
drivers sharing the roadway lock your
brake pedals together so you'll have a
dual braking system if you don't and
your foot slips you might roll the
tractor if at all possible try not to
drive on country roads at night
distances and closing speeds are very
hard to judge when the other drivers can
only see your lights the other drivers
may come up on you too fast to stop it's
their fault but it's your life be
careful before you try to get off the
road the unpaved ground may be very soft
you may end up rolling over also watch
out for mailboxes they are generally
closer to the road in the country the
most dangerous part of driving a tractor
on public roads is turning left when
another vehicle is wanting to pass use
your mirrors to keep track of the other
traffic
make sure all traffic behind you and
oncoming knows that your intention is to
make a left-hand turn use your turn
signal and wait until the traffic stops
to allow you to make the turn safely
after a hard day at work is time to shut
down set the parking brake
try not to park on it in time but if you
must set wheel chocks
but the transmission in neutral lower
all implements to the ground slow the
engine down as far as it will go shut it
off and remove the key from the ignition
wait until morning to refuel when the
engine is cooled this section on the
basic operation of the tractor is very
important and we have a lot of
information to review work hard to
become a master tractor operator when
working near a tractor always assume the
tractor operator doesn't see you never
enter the space between the tractor and
the implement when the engine is running
if you are unfamiliar with the field
walk it first carry your load low with a
front-end loader don't overload don't
try to move round bales of hay without
the proper tool keep your speed down it
will reduce your chances of a rollover
in approaching a blind corner or curves
slow to a speed that you can stop within
sight just slow down when crossing a
slope in bad weather and/or at night
slow down in a thunderstorm
get off your tractor and take shelter
when driving a public highway make sure
the other drivers know your intentions
don't get off a tractor without setting
the parking brakes lowering the
implements shutting the engine off and
removing the key